what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are jumping into venom verse
the official venom verse main story now
again for those of you guys who are new
venom verse is designed to be this venom
equivalent to spider verse now
spider-verse was a lot bigger I mean it
was a far grander story than venom
verses because spider-verse being like
the main title was basically a story
that sprawled throughout the multiverse
and we basically got hundreds of
spider-man you know there were so many
different versions but venom verse is
not based on the main venom story this
is basically just a miniseries that's
kind of thrown out there what we also
did is we covered a series called edge
of venom verse and will actually have
that I'll make a playlist and throw it
down there or I might throw it in with
the main Marvel chronology that meant
major event chronology but edge of venom
verse was just designed for the purpose
of showing us these different versions
of venom from across the multiverse
x-23 venom we got old man Logan venom
gwenpool venom deadpool venom Ghost
Rider Robbie Reyes venom we got these
different versions of the character but
each of them had been recruited by a
venom eyes Captain America for a war
that was going on and we didn't
initially know what the war was we
weren't really given an indication of
exactly what it was that was taking
place but much like the other versions
of venom who were just sort of whisked
away and brought to this alternate
reality the main venom from the Marvel
Universe Eddie Brock was brought here as
well when we're not given an explicit
place of when it is a venom verse
happens we can largely assume that it
takes place between venom legacy issues
151 and 152 or something like that the
idea is that when Eddie Brock is
basically whisked away from the main
Marvel Universe and brought to this
alternate reality the entire world is
basically desolate and for the most part
completely void of life save for these
small little people who are walking
around now of course this brings back
into fray the idea of the venom eyes
Captain America and what we're not
explicitly told what's going on what we
are told is that these people that
individuals are seeing that venom saw is
not an actual person instead it's
basically these small little organisms
that have essentially or at least
presumably consumed all life on earth
and the only individuals who are left
are basically just these versions of
venom now this is where things begin to
get a little hairy because we're not
given an explicit explanation here but
what we are told is that these versions
of venom the reason why they're being
brought to this alternate reality is
being done by this reality's version of
doctor
strange and so the idea seems to be that
someone on the line this race had
basically infected this version of Earth
and when it did dr. strange was
basically venom at the time and
realizing that these things were hunting
after Venom symbiote dr. strange
basically began grabbing these different
versions of venom out of the multiverse
and bringing them together for the
purpose of facing off against these
poisons but again a lot of this stuff is
very cloak-and-dagger in the beginning
we're not given any real explanation all
we're told is that these little
organisms are called poisons and these
poisons serve the purpose of consuming
symbionts but we don't know exactly why
the problem with this is that in the
middle of their whole discussion we end
up finding out that some of the more
prominent versions of super-heroes that
exists out there have been consumed by
the poisons now the idea is that the
poisons are basically driven by the
Venom symbiote that's really the only
thing they serve to do is to consume
them and so we don't know if characters
like this version of The Incredible Hulk
were native to this reality and then
consumed by the poisons or if the
poisons just killed everybody and then
this version of The Incredible Hulk was
a venom eyes diversion from another
universe that was pulled in by dr.
strange and then ultimately consumed by
the poisons we're not really given that
and in truth we don't really need it I
mean we just kind of had these
characters popping up to show us there
are still some you know evil versions of
the characters that are left out there
now at the end of the day where we would
expect a lot of these individuals like
Spider Man you know a lot of these guys
to basically just jump through and
basically be survivors till the bitter
end that's actually not the case instead
we get this almost not teasing of the
idea that we're gonna seek venom
spider-man vs. venom and it seems cool
on the surface but in the middle of the
whole conflict it's basically Doctor
Octopus who was consumed by the poisons
who was presumably a venom at one point
immediately jumps into the fray and in
the middle of it all spider-man is
consumed by one of the poisons becoming
one of their own versions now the other
half of this is remember Eddie Brock has
no clue what's going on right now all he
knows is these things are just running
around and these things are just
attacking people every single human
being is presumably gone you know we use
kind of left to assume they're killed by
their poisons and then whatever
superheroes who were venom is in
different universes or brought here by
Doctor Strange are either continuing to
be venom and fight against the poisons
or have been consumed by the poisons and
joined their ranks and that's where
things begin to get a little hairy
because they don't kill them they don't
eat them and then just call it a day
they essentially bond with them but
again the idea
with Captain America having been
captured by one of the poisons what we
end up finding out is that their ability
to consume and to basically replace a
person is contingent based on the
abilities of that person which is to say
if they just give in then it'll
immediately be a sort of capture that's
the reason why you see things like
Spider Man basically seeing illusions of
like Mary Jane Watson or onme or you
know somebody along those lines and then
it turned is kind of giving himself into
the poisons he's not resisting but in
the case of someone like Captain America
because his will is so strong because
Sharon Carter was presumably killed in
this different reality when he sees her
and is his chance to basically reconnect
with someone who he believes has long
since been dead he lets his guard down
gives up and becomes a capable host for
the for the poison so again things get
kind of cool but it also gives us this
perspective of Spider Man and what he's
capable of
one of the things that keep in mind is
that when it comes to the character of
spider-man he's one of those guys where
for years we knew he was capable but we
just didn't really know what he was
capable of it really wasn't until like
Dan slots run on Amazing Spiderman you
know starting with big time going all
the way up to like dying wish and
suicide run and things like that
well we learned that when Doctor Octopus
took over the body of spider-man during
the events of superior spider-man when
he went to go punch scorpion he knocked
his jaw and that's what it was basically
confirmed to us that spider-man pulls
his punches when he fights against
people and that's kind of the cool thing
is because it really hit home at this
idea this spider-man is a lot more
powerful than people give him credit for
because of his moral perspective
spider-man has pulled his punches
because if he chose to in a fight
against Doctor Octopus he would punch
his head off and that would be the end
of Doctor Octopus so again that's one of
the cool things about it because in this
story writer Cullen Bunn grabs that
concept and brings it in because it's
basically this you know poison version
of spider-man who's been consumed facing
off against an alternate reality version
of Mary Jane Watson who became venom an
alternate reality version of oh man
Logan who became venom Eddie Brock who's
that him all these characters facing off
against every last one of them holding
his own and still being able to come out
on top and so that's why it's kind of a
big deal and that's why it's crazy is
because it feeds back into this idea
that smarter man is extremely capable
now the other half of this is that again
you know he's basically forced to
retreat just because of the fact that
there are so many other versions of
venom descending on him at that point it
just becomes a matter of okay and
regroup and then they try to find a way
to call it a day the issue with this is
that not everybody sides with the idea
of just running around all the time and
that's really what it is a Doctor
Strange said he says look the only
option that we really have is to just
keep on running and see if we can grab
more Venom's and bolster our ranks the
issue with this is that when it comes to
characters like Captain America who have
been turned characters like The Scarlet
Witch
Hawkeye Sabretooth these guys who have
basically been turned into becoming
villains is basically this idea that all
they ever can do is run and if all they
ever do is run they're not making any
headway whatsoever
they're basically just running in
circles they're a gerbil on a hamster
wheel that's it and so the so the idea
of Deadpool is to actually turn himself
in is to basically to sort of walk away
say okay I'm done and be finished with
it and so again it's weird to see
Deadpool kind of turn himself over but
it still is kind of cool
because once he gets his cool looking
uniform and everything he looks pretty
solid but in their efforts in their
last-ditch attempt to basically gather
some sort of being out there who would
be able to overcome these poisons where
all the Venom's failed the idea is to
basically describe someone who would be
a wild card who would be unpredictable
someone that nobody could really plan
for or could expect or anything along
those lines
and so what they end up doing is
reaching into an alternate reality and
bringing out carnage
now carnage is amazing I love the
character of carnage so much because
Cletus Kasady is bonkers carnage is like
the Joker of the Marvel Universe
in a lot of ways right off the bat as
soon as they grab Cletus Kasady and
bring him in it is basically him just
attacking everyone just attacking every
single version of venom and that's a
crazy thing about this is because he
actually overpowers almost all of them
but before things get too hairy and too
far out of control the group is
immediately met by the arrival of these
you know poison versions of iron fist
and the Green Goblin and Captain America
and so on now in truth this is writer
Cullen Bunn kind of nipping things in
the bud before it got too far out of
control now in this instance because
carnage is so extreme what we end up
learning is that the poisons knowledge
of the symbionts is limited to venom
they don't know anything beyond the
Venom symbiote so in this reality is
presumed whatever universe the poisons
hail from venom never gave birth to
carnage they didn't know anything about
carnage now that's kind of the cool
thing about how this works what it does
is it creates this sort of caveat it
creates this weakness in the poisons in
the sense that they don't know what
carnage can do carnage can form his
simian into the claws and different
things like that and all kinds of
stabbing weapons and so on and so forth
in a lot of ways he's more durable with
the notion of carnage being brought in
it's them facing off against him the
best they can but ultimately being
forced to retreat and that's why this is
a good thing because it proves the
carnage is legitimately a weapon that
can be used by the various members of
the venom verse in order to overcome
these poisons and so at this point this
is when we start to get into the idea of
the fact that there's really a
motivation behind the poisons themselves
in terms of what they do how they
function and what their purpose is and
so of course this basically leads to the
capture of Gwyn Poole she basically
begins spilling the beans and what we
end up finding out here is that she at
least from the the poisons perspective
they are the
perfect host for the Venom symbiote in
the sense that they are the one type of
perfect being that the Venom symbiote
seek out and then in turn become the
perfect being they were meant to be the
problem with this is that it's almost
like three beings living in one from the
perspective of the poisons but when the
Venom symbiote bonds with a host
unless that host is perfect unless our
host understands its place perfectly
it's gonna have its own motivations its
own experiences and it's gonna bring
those to the table it's like dating a
crazy girl but the idea here is that she
basically says look well we are
basically fixing you when we consume
someone who they are basically goes away
we essentially destroy that when we
consume spider-man the Peter Parker
aspect of spider-man is gone we maintain
some traces of their personality but the
bulk of what we do is taking over the
the venom Sabaean in its entirety and
bonding with it but what gwenpool
basically presents here is this idea of
a perfect union between the poisons and
the Venom symbiote and that's kind of
cool because what will actually happen
is this will get turned on his head when
Deadpool and these guys basically show
up and they start going through and turn
folks to pieces Deadpool actually ends
up killing Gwyn pool and when he does he
basically says look the whole reason why
I'm here is because I chose to be a spy
now this was a really interesting and an
intriguing turn of events because
historically speaking in Marvel Comics
when it comes to the character of
Deadpool yes he's a wild card in truth
while his moral compass is a little bit
ambiguous at the end of the day the
concept of Deadpool resides around the
notion of the idea that he does what he
believes to be the right thing to do at
any one particular time now that kind of
waxes and wanes but he does have a moral
viewpoint and in this instance him
sacrificing himself to the poisons in
order to serve as a spy of sorts
actually fits in pretty nice and snug
with the kind of publications that we've
seen with his character so far now
something else is also pretty
interesting with this is that : bond
actually plays it pretty smart in terms
of what he does the Deadpool on the
whole we can ask the question if
Deadpool maintains a semblance of
himself even though he's taken by the
poisons who in turn are supposed to
eradicate that semblance how is he able
to maintain that : bond he could have
just said well I mean yo is Deadpool in
his comics whatever and so the the great
middle ground here the great way that :
Bunn does this is basically in this
instance Deadpool saw the Spider Man
kept his sanity for a brief moment for a
very short amount of time and the
Deadpool being as crazy as he is
on the idea that he'd be able to just
kind of keep the Sun out of the poisons
at bay for some short amount of time
however long it'll be but eventually
they'll completely take over him and he
will just be like everybody else in
these moments you know right before he
basically full-on becomes a poison he
basically says look the idea of what
wind pool told you is half true the
whole thing about this is that the
poisons themselves were originally just
some race that existed out there and
they were for the most part pretty weak
but once they realized they were perfect
host for the Venom symbiote their
weakness turned to okay we have meaning
which turned into we can be apex
predators once they began bonding to
these venom symbiotes bond a host of the
Venom symbiote they in turn wanted to
become the dominant species that existed
out there and while they do have dr.
strange captive and while they are
trying to turn dr. strange for the
purpose of grabbing more symbiotes from
the multiverse bringing them in and then
using them as a food source of sorts
what they intend to do is basically
become these perfect house dominate the
Venom symbiote and then just spread
outward into the multiverse infecting
and killing everything they come across
basically putting themselves in a
position where no one can defeat them
this leads with Deadpool basically
overpowering all of the other members of
the venom group who are here and then
dragging carnage directly back to all
the poisons so they can essentially
dissect him and go through and figure
out what he's about and then find a way
to either bond with him with a very at
least find a way to defeat him and then
defeat any other carnage they come
across if they cannot successfully bond
with them the cool thing about this is
we end up finding out that this is
essentially all just one giant ruse that
basically what's going on here is
Deadpool is still on side of the good
guys
Deadpool is maintaining his mind because
he's so insane and so the cool thing
about this is him showing up with
carnage is designed to be basically a
distraction to allow all the other
members to show up where Cletus Kasady
could in turn overpower his restraints
him and Deadpool can take out the rest
of these poison superheroes and then be
done with it the problem with this is
that word does see the return of
spider-man and spider-man in the eddie
brock venom end up facing off against
one another what we end up having is
essentially rocket racoon creating just
like this massive bomb essentially
turning their base of operations into
Obama sorts and then detonating the
whole thing what we never find out about
is what happened Doctor Doom we never
find out what happened to him presumably
he just got blown up but we never find
he's just sort of gone like he just kind
of you know goes in or maybe he grabs a
ship and leaves I'm not really sure but
it doesn't seem to be an explanation on
what goes on everything just sort of
explodes and that's the end of all the
poisons who are there everybody else
gets teleported away back to their
dimensions by Doctor Strange and the
last moments before everything gets
totally obliterated and then that's it
that's where the story if that's what
the story ends there's like no real
resolution to this you know they
basically just win and then we're done
and that's it
now if I if I were a gambling man I
would bet all the money in my pockets to
all the money in your pockets that this
was supposed to have a better ending and
it was supposed to have a more drawn-out
ending but then Marvel Legacy came along
and said nope everything that's going on
right now gets done wrap it up we're
moving into legacy I have no idea if
that's the case or not but I would bet
good money that that's true but
regardless the ending just kind of
heaters out a bit and it's a little
disappointing because the story is
really cool I mean it was really one of
my favorites but then it just kind of
ends and then that's it and it's done
and that's been a verse so without being
said guys we're gonna go ahead and bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come this explain and make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the robb cork if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]